but just not enough against kevin durant  in these nets  chabot a good foul shooter 86  during the regular season and i'm  stunned right now marv  i mean milwaukee was in control  and then kevin durant took over with a  legendary playoff performance  just incredible so burnett's  bounced back from the second afternoon  and the nets now lead this best of seven  three games for two  game six back in milwaukee thursday  night  brooklyn trailed by as many as 17 points  with just under seven minutes remaining  in the third quarter  and they outscored the bucks by 23  after that i mean it's it's incredible i  keep saying that but it is  the thing you worry about though going  back to game six  can the bucks team mentally and  emotionally recover  after being up so big and losing in this  fast